Opioid Buster 1: Stop right there!
Okay, good.
No signs of overdose.
Opioid Buster 2: No need for Naloxone!
Girl Addict: Nalo- What?
Opioid Buster 1: Naloxone.
It treats opioid overdoses.
Opioid Buster 2: Yeah, look on the screen.
It displaces the opioids that bind to the
opioid receptors in the central nervous system.
Weren’t you done with using Morphine?
Girl: Wait a minute!
Who are you guys?!
Opioid Buster 2: Don’t worry about us.
Put that down!
You’ve become dependent on Opioids.
Girl: What can I say?
A little extra medication never hurt anyone?
Opioid Buster 1: Wrong.
In 2017, 47,000 Americans died from opioid
overdoses and 1.7 million were abusing prescribed
opioid painkillers.
Look here!
Opioid Buster 1: See, there are two types
of agonists for opioid receptors.
Opioid Buster 2: We have the endogenous type
,which are naturally made within your body
and here we have exogenous opioids, which
come from nature and are man-made.
OP1: Both types bind to the receptors, like
the kappa-opioid receptor, to relieve pain.
Girl: Wait, how do they do this?
OP2: GPCR.
Opioid receptors are coupled to G Proteins.
When the G protein is activated, it will undergo
a shape change, causing certain activities
in the cell to produce an effect.
OP1: Opioids achieve their effects by preventing
neurotransmitter release.
After the opioid binds to the receptor, part
of the G Protein will bind with the voltage
gated calcium channel.
Calcium is important for signaling, AKA communication
throughout your body.
Without calcium entering the neuron, pain
signaling cannot reach its action potential
and pain relief occurs.
Girl: Wow, so that’s how these pills work.
What happens if I continue taking opioids?
OP2: It will continue engaging with the kappa
opioid receptors and can lead to depression
since dopamine levels decrease in your body.
Opioid Buster 1: Don’t worry, talking to
your doctor can help you face your addiction.
Opioid Buster 2: There are also medication
assisted treatments (MATs) that involve the
usage of both counseling and medicine therapies.
Opioid Buster 1: You can get through this!
Now drop the medication!
Girl: Huh?!?
Where’d they go?